oh wait hang on
hello hello how about now how about now
is it going now it looks like it's going
now okay they have it okay
what the [ __ ] man all right
we didn't say anything like excite other
than me just going what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
do you want to restart no because we
have all that dead time
you can edit yeah but i can trim it
later it's like that that's not a big
deal i usually trim out the
what was it we couldn't see all the
settings look normal we didn't change
anything i know i don't know
what was it what what it was it was this
up here it device had gone to default
for whatever reason doesn't make any
sense who knows [ __ ] poultry guys bro
this [ __ ] shit's haunted i'm telling
you [ __ ]
yeah i'm telling you right now this
kid's haunted
it is yeah it's kind of like my ass is
haunted
that was belladonna yeah i remember
going to
that green looks funny no it doesn't it
just doesn't work
okay you look funny no you look funny
you look funny jenny you're rocking a
green wig
yeah she's got that kool-aid haircut
yeah
yeah i'm trying out some different
colors yeah
what i was saying is uh i was running i
kind of was running late
because um in in the dark room i was
exposing um
yourself don't expose myself no exposing
those two
uh screens to do the new shirts okay
and uh they washed out for some reason
when i went to go spray
it it's a photo active and wanted to go
spray it out after after setting them
i don't know maybe maybe it didn't dry
long enough
yeah i mean that shit's got to dry a
long time and then you have to expose it
way
longer way longer than the other stuff
too because it's it's a new agent that
i'm using
i mean it's the same stuff that i bought
before but i don't know if it's been
i know but i'm just saying that what you
know how in amazon when you order
something and then you go buy it again
i went to buy it again so it was like
the same brand and everything i just
bought a bigger size i bought a quart
inside of a pint it seems to take longer
to um
expo to develop we'll see yeah because i
think the
instructions even say well the
instructions had like 45 minutes and you
need to do it like twice that long yeah
cause i put it in there for an hour and
it's still washed out well and because
parts of it did not all of it we did one
yesterday and you have you exposed that
one for like 80 minutes yeah and that
came out okay
yeah you we gotta way overexpose it yeah
i don't know well maybe because the
maybe because our lights not that right
i only have one ready for production and
it's a it's a new
uh pliskin it's big yeah the image is
big
it looks good it looks really good yeah
it's the same as the other one it's just
like much larger
it's much larger and uh it's good it you
know this
my regular one is good for medium sized
shirts and maybe like larges but this
one will
this one would be good for even like
extra extra extra large
yeah it'll be awesome yeah they look
good on a medium-sized shirt too
well yeah like i said so you know which
it'll just be like a bigger design
but we were trying to do a couple of the
other ones and
i guess we'll just have to do them again
later or tomorrow tila said what
happened
um honestly i don't know like in my obs
thing the device changed from its
regular device to
default or said that the microphone
wasn't hooked up even though it was
so i don't know so i just went up there
and
it doesn't make any sense no it doesn't
it's well i i've
i've given up expecting anything
on this [ __ ] [ __ ] to make sense on
this laptop because nothing does
the the um the settings change without
you changing anything
yeah it's the weirdest [ __ ] thing
ever given the volume level and
sometimes
i've had it happen where because you
know how you go in the settings and
sound or whatever and you can like set
the volume
for whatever for the microphone so i go
in there i have it set at 50. so
like i have gained 50 on this one and i
have 50 on the computer and that's
supposed to be good that's like you know
that sounds good
but every now and then i'll have it now
i'm paranoid so it's like i keep it open
i keep it open
i've had it happen where it was like 50
and i was like okay it's fine
50 okay it's fine 50 okay it's fine and
then i open it again and it was 100.
yeah and i swear to god i didn't [ __ ]
touch it it just does it
and i didn't restart i didn't do
anything it just
it's got pms
it does that's a pretty lame haunting
though if that's like all they do is
[ __ ] just piss me off by turning my
microphone up
yeah but i guess it's working because it
does piss me off a lot
you know what i mean okay let's see
who's here
everybody's here boy they were talking
for a long time
yeah i know well because i was just
sitting here going what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] i'll trim all that out because
it's like
that's i usually do that anyway because
i usually trim out the uh
the beginning where it says starting
soon so i can just trim out up to
up to the fact that we didn't and it'll
be easy to see because if you go in that
youtube editor
you can see where the uh where the what
you call it starts
the sound you know what i mean so i can
just trim it off up to then
uh most of it is them uh just talking
about
sandra who runs in a tube top that's her
new name yeah yeah
[Laughter]
i'd like to see sanders just so i can
just start rocking the tube
in germany in this day and age two top
bell bottoms
high waisted bell bottoms like you could
probably get away with you could wear
that they got to be like high-waisted
poorly fitting
corduroy bell bottoms
yeah yeah but she said man i saw the
picture of your chantelle food because
remember i posted it on instagram
i've never seen such huge servings yeah
it was well when
because they said to me i was like yeah
i want the shrimp man i wanted the
shrimp and grits right so they brought
me the plate and she was like oh you can
get a thing i can't remember what it's
called but it's like it's shrimp and
grits but then it has like some fried
cabbage oh thank oh my goodness thank
you so much
uh no need for me too that is awesome
i had a rough last few days and was
bummed when life kept me away glad to be
back
and despite bad folks interrupting
things life took a turn for the good and
i want to support something that brings
me joy thank you so much that
is so awesome that right there man that
that's uh
i like how it's 49.99
[Laughter]
yeah so well that's what they do that's
like sales 101 that's
always kind of like you know 49.99 it
sounds like way cheaper than fifty
dollars yeah i know it was
50 even though well i always i always
like
round up you know what i mean yeah
because i usually do that anyway because
like i said yeah it's like the sales tax
but yeah she was um yeah so i got
sherman grits and she was like oh we
have another version of that we're at
shrimp and grits but it also has like
fried catfish or i think you get fried
tilapia with it too
and i was like yeah give me the fried
catfish with that like not i thought it
was just gonna be like a little like a
bowl like a grits bowl you know what i
mean like that
it comes out as this plate and it's like
this big and it's like all of this grits
it's like a pile of
you can fried catfish and like a pile of
shrimp and a pile of
sauteed peppers and onions and i was
like oh
my god i couldn't eat all of it tom had
to eat some of it yeah shantae was cool
she was actually very cool looking um
she took me out back
showed me her bike she's got uh three or
four harley davidsons
full dressers and uh
she's a big old big country big fire
black
chick you know he likes [ __ ]
motorcycles and she just she was [ __ ]
funny
she could cook too hell yeah we were
talking about the menu
i was impressed i was impressed she knew
how to cook that catfish right
it wasn't overcooked same thing with
shrimp wasn't overcooked cooked just
right
uh grits good cheese cheese cheesed up
properly
proper seasoning um you know
just southern girl you know she knows
how to do it
and it's like we knew we had heard of
her obviously because it's her
restaurant
but we had never met her before because
we always go there like in the middle of
the night after
man she works in the day yeah so we're
always there like you know two or three
in the morning
so this was actually the first time we'd
been in the daytime and that we'd seen
her
i'll get her on instagram i'll post it
up so you guys can see her
yeah she's yeah she's as cool as [ __ ]
she thought she sat out there and said
i don't talk about us at the table talk
we were the only people inside she had
some customers up front
but uh outside but inside we were doing
inside dining
yeah but uh yeah the only complaint i
had is that
they gave me a to-go nana pudding
instead of one with plate presentation i
complained about it she because you got
what
you know she they gave me yeah
and she called that waitress and they
said don't be hard on her she's not
gonna be hard on her
getting the wrong one she because she
had a nice parfait glass and
you know to put it in she goes she goes
head out no not to give you
the good stuff she's just giving you a
lot more cookies
yeah because those nil away first yeah
i don't like that i don't like nana
anything
i can't go down there too often she'll
try to give me fat
yeah she's one of those you would
definitely just keep trying to feed you
get fat i mean one night we were there
and you know we were drunk and i just
had like a little bit of fish and chips
and we were there with uh will right
yeah
and he's like oh you guys should get
dessert and i think he bought
us a red velvet cake yeah it was good
and it was it was really good but yeah
they give you a big
hunk so we had to split it the cakes
aren't made there though
yeah um she she's ordering those
out they're local production but she's
not so i wanted to
see what she was making and she said she
made that nana pudding so she got it
right
she changed something though she put
cinnamon in it i've never had that it
was good really
i'm pretty sure my grandma used to put
cinnamon in hers my grandmother she made
it she meant a very plain basic way
it didn't have any seasoning in it no
extra spice
it was just the bananas the nilla wafers
and the banana pudding and whipped cream
that was it
michael you said is that the name of the
place chantelle yeah yeah
cantels it's s-h-a-n-t-e-l-l-s and it's
called chantelle's
justin till yeah justin too and it's
like soul food
sanford yeah downtown downtown
which like i said is very small but it's
got like some cool
restaurants like i said there's a ton of
german ones the catfish was good it was
it was uh locally caught
she hires a guy a guy comes with her and
sells it to her he catches it evidently
that's what she said
yeah she said he uh catches the fish in
lake monroe which is like right around
here
and then sells them to her so they're so
it's all local fish yep
which is kind of cool because the
catfish is really good i
haven't tried but you know what i mean
like i said it's we always go in the
middle of the night when we're kind of
drunk so
i had the uh when they're doing karaoke
i had you in the morning i had the
chicken and waffles which is really good
you pour the syrup over the fried
chicken and everything down on top of
the waffle
real good it works out well um but after
after her plate came i was kind of like
oh man i should have got that
it was so good but well i'm glad you got
something else because it's like i
couldn't i really wanted to eat all that
but i was like
yeah there's no way as soon as it
brought out and i hadn't eaten anything
that day but
as soon as it came out i'm like yeah
there's no way i'm gonna be able to eat
all that
yeah michael he says i'm flying to
orlando tomorrow need somewhere to check
out
yeah sanford is about like downtown
sanford is probably what like 18 19
miles
from downtown orlando so i don't know if
you're flying into like orlando
international airport or if you're
flying into sanford orlando
international airport if you ever want
to come to this area you want to fly
into sanford internet at sanford airport
that's where
presidents come in and everything it's a
it's a fully equipped airport but it's
re it's small
very small real nice it's never busy
so when you land you just walk out it's
much easier
much much easier i mean no traffic the
orlando
uh airport is kind of a claustrophobic
well i know that any large
and honestly i've been to the atlanta
airport which is a massive [ __ ]
i've been to the denver airport also a
massive [ __ ] jfk i've been there
uh gatwick in the uk so you know the
orlando one is
only three or four woody columns what do
you call those things at airports
terminals
terminals thank you thoughts i couldn't
talk for whatever reason i couldn't
think of the word
so it's only i think they only just
built a third one but
i don't know why it's like the traffic
around there like the way they have the
roads laid out around there just gives
me [ __ ] hives i [ __ ] hate
[ __ ] hate having to go to that
[ __ ] terrible and i hate it you see
we live in a pre we live in a we live on
the border of sanford and heathrow
this is this used to be kind of country
and rich houses
now it's it's it's upper middle class
area
the housing complex is all new it was
built during the time we were here
half of this [ __ ] even again put a damn
traffic light out on our back gate
that's bothered me
when i got traffic lights around your
[ __ ] house man you know the shit's
and then a couple blocks away there's a
damn new freeway on ramp off-ramp right
over there i can't believe that but man
i feel like i'm downtown it's not done
yet
yeah but i'm sure like all the people
that own those houses like right under
where they put that for
probably like [ __ ] me because they
probably paid like four hundred thousand
five hundred thousand dollars for those
houses and now it's gonna be all like
freeway noise
anyway up this road right here at the
corner you go up and it's just
it's a street called markham woods road
there's nothing but just mansions
and horse farms and horse farms like big
acreage and there's some golf courses
and [ __ ] like that got all the
basketball players that live on one
street over here
they're [ __ ] mcmansions they're nice
houses uh
the guy who owns ace hardware lives
right over here and he's gonna [ __ ]
huge compound
so they built and then there's a couple
really nice even bigger
um developments maybe about a mile up
the road here you know the intersection
the intersection is yeah
uh i forgot what the name of that
[ __ ] intersection is anyway
uh 427 no i don't know the names of
these roads i just drive by
anyway i know i'm like hey drive up to
46. i'm like what the [ __ ] is that i
grew up here
i'm like i'm like that's the road with
the ace hardware and the publix
yeah well they built that airport
because of this neighborhood over here
because some of these people are [ __ ]
okay like when orange man was in town he
flew in there and he stayed up here in
his
one of these houses over here i'm gonna
give him away i know who it was i know
where he was living
his whole [ __ ] buttercage and [ __ ]
it's it's nice over here
it's all like brand new and the thing is
it's kind of low key it's nowhere near
as flashy as say like miami they got
some
neighborhoods in miami that blow your
[ __ ] mind
they got streets and they got
watered ducks so you can drive up to
your house in your car or your boat
that's [ __ ] blowing my mind man matt
snoop dogg's got one of those
yeah yeah he did that movie evidently
that was his neighborhood
oh yeah that movie that we saw it's new
was that the one that we saw in the
theater yeah yeah yeah yeah that
evidently was his neighborhood
the beach bomb beach bomb or something
right wasn't matthew mcconaughey
yeah harmony korean movie
that was a weird ass movie it was pretty
good though
but um yeah i did well i just kind of
feel like
i don't know i kind of like i don't like
being too far out in the country
because i don't i don't know how long to
get to the globe it takes too long to
get
to places i don't want to have to drive
[ __ ] 10 miles to go to a [ __ ]
grocery store
or something like that it's a pain in
the ass um
when you're old man you don't go
anywhere maybe it might be worth it but
that's what i mean it's just like i
don't know i don't
like i said my mom and my stepdad like
kind of live out in the middle of
nowhere
like it's not nowhere nowhere like up
around there's other houses around and
there's like a convenience store up on
the corner and there's a walmart like
five four or five miles away something
like that
so it's not like they're out in the
middle of the [ __ ] australian outback
or anything
but i don't know i just i don't like it
it creeps me out i just i i watch too
many horror movies
and it's just kind of like well you know
if somebody decided they were gonna
[ __ ]
you know do a home invasion or something
like that it's like really not a lot you
could do about it i mean he was looking
at
house menu online yeah it's good they
got
they got um cobbler i asked her
yeah and she makes it i didn't know i i
should have asked her if it was the kind
with the self-rising flour
my grandmother used to make the recipe
with self-rising flour which that's the
cheaper easier way to do it but that's
the more
southern way of doing it by using the
cheap and easy [ __ ]
and it gives you this damn chewy kind of
bread
it's chewy and crispy because of all the
sugar that's [ __ ] baked in on top you
know what i'm talking about yeah
yeah and it starts off on the bottom but
then when it starts to rise
it rises up through the peaches and ends
up being on the top
it's like you know what it's like magic
yeah then you take it out of there with
a spatula put whipped cream on it
or if you really want to get white trash
you put cool whip on it instead of
whipped cream
cool whip that's going 70s man
i mean cool whip cool whips kind of good
though
yeah it's not whipped cream but it looks
good
but it's its own thing yeah yeah you
know what i mean yeah
it's kind of like the equivalent of you
know how there's miracle whip
but it's sort of like not mayo yeah
but kind of right although i don't
really like miracle whip it's yeah
they're neutral it has like a weird
tangy kind of taste that i'm not into
i was reading an article the other day
that apparently
since we're talking about food um that
apparently a lot of people have
uh an aversion to
[Music]
white condiments like goopy condiments
like mayo ranch dressing
stuff like that yeah apparently that's a
pretty common
food version i just wondered about that
i'm not a huge fan of
i don't know not a huge fan of ranch
dressing although it's not right
sandra said she made cobbler today uh an
american recipe used apple cobbler yeah
yeah yeah another one that's good is uh
blackberry
you get the blackberry pie filling you
put that in your cobbler
yeah blackberry cobbler it's real good
put that in your cobbler put that in
your car
same thing
[Laughter]
yeah michael he says orlando's airport
is
away lax is less crazy even though it's
so much bigger
yeah i don't really know i think what
might have happened with the orlando
airport which is kind of
uh a microcosm of what happened with the
whole orlando area
is that there wasn't much in orlando
until disney world got built you know
what i mean the park and then they
started expanding with all the resorts
and [ __ ]
and i don't think they were really
prepared for
how many people you know how many
tourists would come here and also how
many people would end up moving here
and so it seems like we're constantly
having to play catch-up
because you know the roads aren't big
enough and it's like you know what i
mean they're constantly having to like
widen i-4 they're always working on i-4
because it's just that
you know orlando's expanding so much so
yeah
it's like so many people done with it
it's time to expand
it's already like backed up again and
they have to like make it bigger
it's better now than it was but it's
like when i used to commute every day
man that was a [ __ ] nightmare it's
like it took like an hour and a half to
get
anywhere sandra saw the photographs of
that chantal's meal that you bought
yeah that's what we were talking about
yeah she thought that was just a rumor
that americans had huge
oh no it's not [ __ ] servings no okay
it depends on where you're going if
you're somewhere
in new york or boston and you go to his
little fufu
nouveau cuisine or health type places
it's going to be expensive and very
small you're not going to get anything
but that's not going to be the situation
if you go to a mom pa restaurant
especially if it's southern
no no or a chain store
yeah tgiy fridays they're gonna overfeed
you
because let's just talk about a chain
restaurant
some of those big chain restaurants
that food costs them pennies especially
[ __ ] like
french fries and sides it doesn't cost
them anything
so to give you a big portion does not
cost them any more really
same price but what it does for you
is that you think that you've gotten
more for your money
which will encourage you to come back so
they're just what's wrong
my [ __ ] crashed i was just making sure
that yeah this guy right here is acting
funny already
so